all right how we doing today guys great
how are you I'm so happy to talk about
this book I loved it and I love the
flavor this book is and it's so
approachable and I think that's so
important for a book that's setting up a
whole world of books and that's really
exciting for me where did the idea come
from to start with this character in
particular I pitched this series to DC
but I pitched origin stories and group
books because coming from ye I felt like
I really wanted the readers to be able
to get invested in like have an
adventure with the character and I
didn't know if they'd go for it and they
totally did so now we're gonna have
origin stories and then I also pitched a
group book but I just thought it'd be
more fun if we get to know them before
they hang out absolutely and when you
first found out this particular
character Ravens got such a legacy such
a beautiful history how was it finding
your voice in the shape of the character
through your pen I've been drawing a lot
of same titles fan art before getting
hired to do this book so I already had
this look going on I take a lot of
inspiration from the animated cartoon
which was what introduced me to the here
to these superheroes so I already had
like a look that the DC was looking for
for this line which is this relatable
more down-to-earth I static for for
these zeroes yeah they didn't
reinterpret it a few times most recently
Titans and I think that's one of the
strengths of these characters is they're
so versatile you can make them your own
in your own way was that something that
drew the Titans in particular I'm a huge
Titans fan Raven I can really relate to
Raven I I was kind of I wasn't and I had
a lot of friends but I still feel kind
of different in high school and I
remember that feeling
I taught for 17 years I spent time with
teens she's just to me a great character
because she's not OneNote you know she
encompasses light and dark she's got a
struggle you know with her like with her
inner demons literally but also
metaphorically and you know I've always
related to her I think she's great
one thing Gabriel does that's really
unique is he was drawing them in red
clothes like not costumes so I saw his
work on Pinterest and I was like he is
perfect because what I want them to do I
want them to look like you know Raven
could be your best friend or sitting
next to you in English class yeah so
that you could really get their
relatability without stripping away the
things that are special about her and
one of the things that I really loved
and speaking of the art tying into the
the verbage is the color use draws you
to certain parts of the panel but it
also reflects in the verbage and I love
that your attention is going to this
part of the panel this part of the panel
how much did you guys work together in
shaping all of that as part of the
narrative we were trying to initially I
we were going to do like full color but
then I think is more muted I setec it
works better for the book as a whole
because it's a long book so you can just
see everything in one sitting because
everything's like so pleasing and like
muted you know so well who's the head of
the line but also our editor really had
a vision in which he saw Gabriel's color
and everything she had this vision for
the line of just like kind of having a
subtle sophistication that would run
through the books to kind of also just
like honor the art yeah because like I
mean I have a love for pencils and so
when she kind of brought it that option
to us we loved it and then we just
worked with Gabriel's colors and David
Calder on who's you know an amazing
colorist to get the palette but it was
interesting because it not it was such a
natural fit yeah it's one of my favorite
parts of the book is that it's so unique
but it still feels like a comic book and
it's a graphic novel in its own way but
it has that beating heart and your RX
reminds you of mike ringo who's one my
favorite artists of all time
and i loved the cartoon sensibility but
still photo real flavor and new orleans
is captured so beautifully through both
the verbage and the art it almost is a
character in this book and how important
was that to you to have New Orleans be a
beating heart of this my original
co-authored series with markers stole a
beautiful creatures the these settings
were basically considered characters by
everyone so something I'm kind of known
for doing and DC said you know we love
Gotham Matar opposite like we would kind
of love it if you would pick a new place
like if you get some new places
and it was there was kind of like you
know maybe the south and so I was like I
knew New Orleans right away because it's
such a unique place yeah and she's a
unique character but the real challenge
was obviously Gabriel had never been
there and a lot of references that's
what it was like to do New Orleans like
as someone who had not seen the city
like I was at Cafe Du Monde man like
those beignet seem that means a lot
because especially because I'm not like
environments are not my strong my
strongest suit when I'm drawing and
getting to draw the place that is so
interesting so unique as as New Orleans
was very interesting for me as an artist
like it piqued my interest my interest
immediately yeah so I relied a lot on
references because me and Cammie we were
exchanging those sort of references all
the time I actually only got to see New
Orleans for the first time earlier this
year after I was done with the book but
it was interesting cuz I got to see a
lot of stuff that I had to draw the
previous yeah you get to find your own
panels yeah yeah exactly and already
drawn yeah amazing that was very
interesting our friend took him on like
a walking tour of the book like that's
cool he gets experienced Google Maps
through exactly that's it storytelling
in this is really great because it's a
character whose origin is known but you
get to retell it your own way and the
use of amnesia really allows for that to
be your voice and I also like that the
the pen gets more detailed as her story
gets more detailed you can find things
in that when you were mapping the story
out did that change when the amnesia
started or was it always this consistent
like going into the second act she finds
herself yeah for me the trick was I
really loved the Raven that Marv Wolfman
and George Perez created and so I wanted
to keep as much of the character I loved
as I could but also add something new
and make it relatable to people who
might not you know might think oh I
don't
I'm not into graphic novels like I
really want to change their mind yeah so
one of the things was I didn't want to
lose her origin story but starting out
with her knowing that about herself
would have been very difficult so I just
decided you know what like I'm I like to
do the thing people say you can't do so
I'm like I can make em nice you're fresh
and so my whole arc for her was you know
I am all for a strong heroine but not
every teenage girl starts out strong a
lot of them think they're not strong and
they have to find dig deep and figure
out that they are so I wanted her to
start out as kind of like unsure and
then over the course of the book you see
her find that inner strength and you see
it come forward and I love the
relationships that form from that all
the relationships feel authentic and the
romance man like it's hard to capture
romance and not feel like clawing and I
think you really got that especially
with them - what was what was some of
your influences in framing the way you
did so I have this original story which
is what I'm most famous for besides my
Teen Titans work occurs in the Sun and
it's about a relationship so that's a
thing that I absolutely love to draw
relationships dialogues characters in
general but romance is a thing that I
it's one of my favorite things to draw
so I I'm glad I can we put that on the
on the screen like the almost kissing oh
yeah yeah you remember high school you
remember that feeling like I'm gonna
come from but this is great oh no what
have I done
now with this specific art style who
were some of your influences in the
economic space growing up was were you a
comic-book kid I was not especially cuz
in Brazil there's no comic book shops at
all so especially when I was a kid was
even harder to get into comics so that's
why I relied a lot on the Teen Titans
cartoon to get me into the comics
because I got hooked up on comics later
on when I was in high school so for this
specific novel my my inspirations were
Jorah he - he was working it's on super
Suns I love how dynamic his pahis poses
are I love his graphic style I love
ultimate he's a Russian artist also
working for DC he was doing the ring
arrow the iconic of rebirth Green Arrow
and his tie with transitions a lot from
cartoony to more comic-book ish style so
that's that's an approach that I also
try to follow the kinetic energy of
humanness I totally see here that's
absolutely yeah I see that now when you
were first approached to expand this
universe out what made you decide like I
know we can't talk
too much because I'm excited to read it
not know but beast boys next what why
was that the number two what well I
think Raven was num beast boy's
Gabriel's favorite Ravens my favorite
from then second favorites the other way
so I think since I was in the meeting
and he wasn't hired yet I was like I
want to do Raven and then you know Beast
Boy is so fun and you know he's tying to
do Beast Boy like I couldn't feel like
we were gonna do something else in
between so I was not sure I will get to
draw Beast Boy I was like hoping hoping
like praying every day like that I would
get this book after I got this book I
had to hold it hold the secret for like
half an year that was Stella stuff I was
like dropping hints whenever I could but
I couldn't talk about it you know well
it's my favorite character so I'm having
a blast working on it and it's fun
because you know Beast Boy
always comes across in the you know and
the younger versions the teen version of
Beast Boy you know he's like super funny
he's always cracking jokes and I wanted
to keep all that but I also wanted to
see like what else is there because
obviously like you can be funny and have
a great sense of humor but that doesn't
mean you know you don't have problems
and things aren't bothering you yeah
absolutely and you don't have other
stuff going on so I wanted to kind of
dig into that as a fan of the character
that's my favorite part of drawing this
story because there's there's so much
more than just just a comic relief just
to the side of the side of peace boy
that everyone already knows you know
sure that's why I light like kyle rayner
the Green Lantern he's got like the
darkest stuff going on but he's the most
funny of the Green Lantern's in my
opinion and I feel like Beast Boy is a
comic relief that uses that as a defense
mechanism exactly how that's my take -
and I'm fascinated to see with this
style because I love the young adult
take how would that be I'm very excited
for Beast Boy if you can't tell like I'm
twitching to find out to follow this up
and I love the amount of purple in this
and I'm excited to see like the use of
green I'm excited to see this this
palette as its formed is there ever a
character in another medium you guys
want to touch on like outside of the the
world of titans we have some some
secrets going okay secrets between us if
we can't share I love big black I just
do you know in the back of Raven there's
a little preview of Beast Boy because
you were mentioning really wanted to see
something green
so I thought I might just tell you that
for later okay perfect it's right now
like right now live guys I got to
experience now with this book it turns
into a full-fledged origin story by the
end where we catch up to the Raven that
is that is the Raven we all know and it
introduces there's a character in here
that's very iconic to the world and it's
only T's was that intentional is there
gonna be more of that character in other
iterations I mean there might be he's
like one of my favorite character okay
good because it's very important
character to me was there anything in
this book that surprised you while
you're developing it like a page that
you thought of and it just kind of
organically appeared I mean I always
beat out the main beats but there was a
lot of kind of like dialog like where I
thought I knew which the characters were
gonna say but especially max who we
developed who's Ravens foster sister
since that's not a character I knew as
well it's like after a while she would
just be like no I'm not saying that this
is what I'm saying yeah and there were
just some moments where also I would see
Gabriel's art and like after I saw it I
was like this is what he would say to
her this is what they would say to each
other oh that's really cool he went
aback yeah so I would I change the
script a lot and luckily I had
flexibility because the letterer didn't
have a lot of those pages yet so I would
just go back the minute I got the art
and look in case see if I need to change
anything that's fantastic and otherwise
I think a lot of cool pages came out and
it was not predicted for predictable
from the layout because when you see the
layouts it's just like some sticky
figures and like some some panels and
some lines and then you you it turns out
into the beautiful pages so I especially
loved the ending and I think it's the
part that I got to draw the the best
illustrations off in this book so I can
talk about obviously because everything
is gonna be a spoiler but that was my
favorite part too drawing because
there's so much so much action and so
much so much stuff going feelings all
day all over the place so it's a really
exciting moment of the book and while
we're staying vague Max's power set I I
really love the way it's Illustrated
because it feels both like New Orleans
and an authentic version of her power
set and it was interesting because I
don't think of this character's taking
place in New Orleans
for obvious reasons but with this that
ties into Mac so beautifully what was
the idea for that do it like were you in
New Orleans and that struck you or have
you always wanted to write that story I
have spent a lot of time in New Orleans
um I have gone there over the years
beautiful creatures was filmed there I
spent a lot of time hanging out in
cemeteries over the long weekend I just
feel like it's a place where it feels
like magic is kind of alive and well
yeah there's you know ancestral history
there's you know so much reverence for
the past and so I just felt like that
was a place where something could be
hidden in plain sight very easily mm-hmm
and also there's a you know my family my
mom's family's from a small town in the
south like you they believe in spirits
and things like that like that's not a
unheard-of thing so I also wanted Raven
to be able to have a person that when
she wanted to open up that person would
be like oh yeah like par for the course
you know like I've heard about that like
yeah where it's not like oh you know
like we need to really talk about you
know your level of reality are you okay
I wanted someone who would be able to to
least you know try to understand and
believe her absolutely that makes total
sense um and and having never been there
like it once again you really captured
that flavor and it must have been
surreal to be there after is there
anything in the world of comics now that
you've kind of been in this world you
didn't get to grow up with it but now
you're in there is there like a gateway
book you'd recommend to people that you
really enjoy coming into comics a
gateway book my first comic sort of the
book that got me into comics hooked up
into comics again was the Burnside
Batgirl
DC the artists in this project I love
them so much to this day I've followed
your work online so that's a book that I
totally recommend I would say super Sons
because it's such such an interesting
story and is it's so so alive and full
of action I totally recommend it to if
you want to get into superhero comics
that I will totally recommend this if
you're not interested in heroes I
recommend reading Raven because you know
it's a more why a approach of
superheroes so yeah I totally agree if
it fits both sides of the Khattab
spectrum and I think that's definitely a
strength and I love the fact that
I can recommend this to people that
don't read comics and then they might
read comics yeah is there anything you
discovered while you were getting into
this world that you really think Sam I
love Mariko Tamaki and Giles Jones is
being super mm-hmm
and again because I feel like it has oh
it's it's a super Easter but as a real
story to it and if you're not like a
die-hard superhero fan you can just like
enjoy it for that but the sake of that
I'm also a huge super Suns fan I also
love Gotham Academy I love lumberjanes
I'm like yeah like I just love
Libertines and then if it's like more
comics like you know I love monstrous
and I read also adult so right right and
it's a really good time to be a comic
book fan because it's such a wide swath
yeah and they're really approachable
right now and I think DC's done a really
good job letting the classic characters
be reintroduced in so many different
ways as we wrap this up you were talking
about Marv Wolfman and Marv Wolfman I
think is such a brilliant mind and he's
so great about the world adapting his
work in new ways George Perez as well
what was one of the favorite things you
glean from from talking to Marv so I got
set up on like a supposed like
accidental lunch meeting with him that
was totally orchestrated and I said like
you know what you know do you have any
advice and he said you don't need to
listen to me
like I don't want don't do what I did I
want you to do your own thing and he
said something to the effect of like I
just believe that like Raven is is as
important now as she was when I
originally wrote her and I want like new
readers and generation to like fall in
love with her and love her as much as I
do and so I was like I can do that I did
you definitely did these characters
justice both you thank you guys so much
for making a book that is for comic fans
and non comic fans alike I couldn't put
this book down and it's quite the read
to keep you going and it reminded me of
my own like life which is such a hard
thing to capture when dealing with
demons so that's I mean for some so
thank you both so very much I cannot
wait for Beast Boy because beast boy's
my favorites there check it out it is on
the stands right now wherever comics and
books are sold it is so good thank you
so much for Raven and thanks for joining
us today guys thanks for having us